We're going to have a look at today, something that's, uh,
been hitting the headlines and we're going to be talking about this compound
here. Rejoice is under the acronym too, for DMP.
So that stands for dine nitro,
fennel hydrazine you particularly so we'll appreciate it because it's trivial
name is Brady's reagent,
but it also rejoices under the trivial name of Bosch is region. Well,
I guess what we'd like to start the story with is taking you way back
to the Dawn of organic chemistry in maybe the 1750s through to
about 18 hundreds.
All of the modern techniques that as a student or as a member of the public that
we learn about the full of martyr of modern analytical techniques are not
available. In fact,
the only technique that's available is to measure the melting point of your
compound, and that kind of can create some, uh, difficulty for you.
And I've got an example here that we're going to look at this morning.
So this is a popular compound. This is a compound of benzene.
It's a derivative and it has an aldehyde group on it. But as you can see,
there's going to be an intrinsic problem with measuring the melting point of
Ben's out a high in that it's a liquid.
And if melting points are the only thing you can do is you need a way to be sure
that everything that's in that aldehyde or carbon IO class,
you can turn into a solid that you can then even measure the melting point,
even in 1750. And that's the essence of the Rady's reagent or DMP,
something that you can be sure that you can react an aldehyde or a ketone with
to give you a solid crystalline reagent. And back in the day,
it would come as a solid.
So what we're going to do now is we're going to look at the original formulation
of the DMP Brady's reagent as it was supplied up until I
guess, uh, probably about a year and a half. Okay. So we're in here.
So we're going to have to do a bit of mining because this has been packaged up.
This is just secondary containment. So this is just a plastic outer shell.
And now we can get to the beast in its original form,
and you can see here's the D for the die.
There's the end for the nitro and there's the P for the phenol hydrazine.
So D N P gives you the, uh, Brady's reagent.
If the compound is normal, unrelated, correctly,
it'll be completely safe and stable, and we have no need to worry,
but if it's dry,
then that's when all the fun and games and excitement starts.
So I've deliberately selected, uh,
a compound where I believe it to be dry.
So I'm just going to point that away from me a little bit and just open up
gently. So the compounds not terribly volatile.
So I'm handling this in a hood, but, uh,
what we're going to do is probably get a sheet of paper in here so that we can
put a little bit out so that you can see and you brought,
you should see if we can spoon some out is a
highly bright orange. Now these are not,
crystals are aggregates where the small little microcrystals have all started to
come together. As it's drying out, when it dries out,
then the reagent can become more unstable. It can suffer an order,
catalytic decomposition. So order could tell us,
this is where the products of a reaction encourage the reaction to become
faster, which generate more products so that it becomes even faster.
And of course, that's how you get a runaway reaction.
And that's what we call an explosion. Um,
we're going to test that a little bit later,
but let's actually focus on why the reagents used and why it's useful.
And let's take you back again to the 1750s.
And if you remember, we had, uh,
this compound benzaldehyde where clearly we don't have a solid,
so we would like to make a solid derivative of it.
We would have to take the solid and we would have to dissolve it.
And that'll take us a little bit of time.
So what we're going to do is use the luxury of modern chemistry.
And what I've done here is, as they say in blue, Peter,
here's what I prepared earlier.
So this is just a solution of this orange compound. I put it into solution.
And so what you should see here, I hope has a bright orange solution come up.
Right? Okay. So we're going to try and turn our benzaldehyde into a,
into a solid.
Now I just mentioned that chemists like to do all of their reactions in
solution. So we're going to use methanol.
We're just going to use that as a solvent for the reaction.
So we need to get both, uh, our orange hydrazine and our carbon,
our compound in the same solution. So I'm going to take some, uh,
benzaldehyde here. And what I'm going to do is do a,
not terribly stoichiometric reaction. So we're going to take,
that'll probably about, be about a 150, a hundred, 200 milligrams,
something like that. So we'll put that into the solvent.
Let's put the lid back on here, ends out a high desert,
very nice smell of almonds, but it's like toxic, super toxic.
And now we need to switch and see if we can get this to make a
precipitate. So let's see a benzaldehyde has got a, uh,
a mass of about a hundred. So we've got about two millimoles in here.
This is about 0.2 molar. So we need a, a reasonable amount of this,
the right reaction of DMP, or Brady's reagent with aldehydes,
uh, depends on the substrate. And it can take anything from instantaneous up to,
uh, several hours. So, right.
So let's just stop there. Oh, look, there you go.
[Inaudible].
So, as you can see, we've got almost instantaneous reaction.
We've produced from our original liquid.
Benzaldehyde a large clump of a bright orange, yellow
Chemists, like to use names to describe their derivatives.
So we started a hydrazine. So this derivative is a Hydrostone. Okay.
So we've talked a lot about the chemistry of DNP and why it's really useful,
but it won't have escaped your attention that in media recently,
there's been a lot of concern over Brady's reagent,
DNP as a potential source of explosion, the compound,
as it was originally formulated damp,
perfectly safe in the modern version that we've shown you perfectly safe.
The compound does have a reputation though,
for being what is called shock sensitive,
meaning that if the compound is subjected to friction or sudden energy through
an impact, it can detonate.
That's not so well described actually in the scientific literature.
And so in the cause of science,
what we're going to do is try and make a brief investigation at a small and
therefore potentially safe scale to indicate what the degree of shock
sensitivity is as formulated in wet.
There shouldn't really be that much shock sensitivity in Brady's reagent.
But like I said,
there's very little data and we're not going to take any chances. So I,
I'm not gonna put on not just a face mask, but this is an explosion face mask.
And if it explodes, it'll protect my face still. Uh, and I'm going to,
don't want to lose any fingers.
So I'm going to go for some protective gloves as well,
chest the shock sensitivity.
I'm going to use this highly expensive scientific piece of apparatus available
from any good hardware store. And we're going to strike the compound,
not accessibly hard because it shouldn't need that. If it, if it's going to go.
So I'm going to give it a light tap and then we'll see one, two, three
that I think is me missing. So we'll do that again. One, two,
three, we struck the compound.
We might want to come in and have a look at back and see here at the back.
This is where it was struck with a hammer, quite vigorously,
no effect whatsoever. You can make the comparison against the material.
That's jumped off the front here. These are exactly the same color, uh,
and that's quite a decent strike. Okay?
So what we should do now is let's dry the compound out and see if it makes a
difference. So again, the literature is not too clear. Uh, and in,
in view of safety concerns,
we're going to be a little bit vague about how long we're going to dry this
compound,
but we're going to put it on this hot plate that you can see in the back of the
hood.
You can see the red flashing light indicating that the hot plate is heating.
And if you look closely at the dial here,
you can see it's set at just over 100 degrees C,
so that should drive off any water. And then we'll rerun our shock test.
And we're going to put that on the hot flight. And now,
as they say, in the fire code, retire to a safety,
Okay.
So we're back in part two of the great shock detonation story.
So while we've been away having a cup of tea, what we've left is our hot plate,
which you can see in the background there. And we've been cooking up our DMP.
So we're up at the top here and on three, two,
one,
this compound is not accessibly shock sensitive.
Okay. But what I should add at this point of course,
is we've done this under a very controlled condition.
We've done this with a very small amount of material.
The compound has a reputation for shock sensitivity.
Therefore there have been detonations in the past.
Clearly we've done this for you today,
so that you can see and feel confident in, uh, in the chemistry. But, uh,
I wouldn't advise you to take any 14 pound sledgehammers and dustbins full of
them.
Depression. Doesn't expand very rapidly.
One of the things that I thought was interesting is that when a bubble catches
fire, the burning gas continues to move up.